I think that's normal all right thank
you great thank you for joining my
presentation about continuous gflow Nets
uh this presentation is a
main following a paper that was
published in icml this year which was
joint work with Triston Pablo uh
jingai Alex Sasha
Lena uh Kia and yosua I hope I didn't
forget anyone I should have written that
uh I guess like the first question to
ask is why do we need continuous gifl
Nets and you have probably understood
from the previous presentations today
that gfets have proven advantages either
theoretically or experimentally compared
to mcmc compared to reinforcement
learning and to variational inference so
compared to any of these three domains
like there are gonets have some
advantages for example of policy
learning helps G flets more than varion
inference uh we can sample proportion to
rewards rather than Max imaginary reward
as in reinforcement learning Etc and
also these proven advantages have been
confirmed in many discrete domains
discrete scenarios for example in
biological sequence design where the
goal is to construct molecules or
biological sequence by concatenating
small building blocks such as small
molecules or
maybe small proteins in
general it has been confirmed in Bion
structure learning where the goal is to
learn a a graph or a duag that describes
the generative process of a given data
set and here the construction of such a
dug is done sequentially by the addition
of edges directed edges between
different nodes it has been confirmed in
the robust scheduling problem where the
goal is to assign a set of operations to
different compute nodes or threads which
is known to be an NP hard problem and
the G flets have been shown to be useful
for that and actually it's it's it's
probably still state-ofthe-art
today uh it has been used uh for
discrete image modeling
uh this is a paper that was published a
year or so ago where and the image you
see here is bin binarized Mist where we
construct uh these images of numbers
that are uh binary so just ones and
zeros uh given like a set of uh uh of
images and the way this is trained is uh
with maximum likelihood training that
has been presented by in the last talk
and
probably many I mean not probably but
like surely many other discrete
scenarios in which gonets have been have
been proven to be
advantages so with these two points the
fact that there are many advantages and
the advantages have been proven in
discrete domains uh there is the
question I mean the fact that there are
many interesting sampling problems that
do not exhibit this discrete like
structure uh you know this is what
drives us to create a theory for
continuous G flets and these problems
that do not exhibit a discre deck
structure I'll I'll cite a few of them
the first one being Bion structure
learning with parameters so if we go
back like to the vision structure
learning in the discrete case where the
goal was just to learn the the graph
which is a discrete object because we
just need to create to to create edges
or like to learn where where to put
edges between the nodes
here we also want to learn the
parameters and the parameters are
uh in such basian basian dag the parent
of a node influences its children and
this influence is captured by a function
that can be parameterized either as a
linear function or by a neural network
and in addition to learning the edges
that tell us which are the parents and
which are the children we also need to
learn the parameters of these
functions uh another interesting problem
is learning molecular confirmations so
in addition to learning the the molecule
structure uh we also sometimes need to
learn the angles between some of the the
edges or maybe like the bones that's
maybe like the more correct term in
molecules uh given that these angles
influence the energy of the molecule
some molecules with some angles are more
stable are more suited for for a given
task and finally a last task that comes
to mind is image Generation Well colored
image generation where we we are not
limited to only ones and zeros where we
can choose what color we want for every
pixel and obviously you can think of
many other scenarios where uh the
sampling problem does not exhibit the
discrete Dex
structure so I believe like with these
three points uh it's obvious that uh to
ask the question of whether there is an
equivalent of G in the continuous
domains and whether this advantages
transfer to The Continuous
domains and before answering the
question I will give you a summary of uh
of of the paper of the of what we found
why while working on this and the answer
is yes and there are few details to be
aware of when training a g flowet in a
continuous domain and I'll start by
reminding you of uh the two main losses
that are used in the discrete settings
the detailed balance and the trajectory
balance uh and for the detail balance
I'm not writing the the boundary
conditions where we incorporate the
reward but you know like
that's that's something that that should
be added to the detail balance of course
and I just want you
to to see that here in the detailed
balance and the the trajectory balance
the policies we we care about are
parameterized by their probability Mass
functions so the the pmf here it's the
probability Mass functions the policy
PFS Prime given s is a probability Mass
function condition s and sometimes we
need State flows so as Kia mentioned
when when we when we don't use the flow
matching conditions we need extra
objects such as the state flow function
and the backward policy which is also a
pmf uh and for the teror balance but
also for the balance of course we we
need the reward
function so for the continuous
counterpart we also have a detailed
balance and trajector balance losses uh
and the equations look very much like
the discrete ones except that now uh for
example for the detailed balance we do
not deal with pmfs probability Mass
functions but we deal with PDFs the
probability density functions so here
pfss Prime is a probility density
function of S Prime condition s uh same
thing instead of a state flow function
we have a state flow density function
and I'll I'll talk a little bit about
the details later and again uh instead
of the re function we talk about a
reward density
function but besides these three
differences also of course for Pb the
equations look pretty much the
same uh so we can maybe like stop the
talk here and say that yeah of course
you can turn a g flownet just use
PDFs uh instead of pmfs and use the same
losses with the in the log domain to
make it more
stable uh but I'll delve a little bit
into the details
now so the first question uh that's
which is important to answer is you know
in the discrete domain the structure is
well described by a dag we have parents
we have children we know that in order
to go from one state to another we have
to go through this dag this D captures
the structure we want uh but in
continuous domains it's a little bit
unclear how to talk about or how to
generalize the concept of children or
how to generalize the concept of parents
it might be a little bit weird to talk
about Continuum of children or Continuum
of
parents uh but still we need a way to
describe something that looks like a dog
structure in a more General
space um
uh so we need some mathematical tools to
replace this dag that we use in the
discrete domain uh and we need this
mathematical tool to satisfy a few thisd
the first one being we want to be able
to describe a Continuum of children or
par and parents as I mentioned uh and we
want disc continuity with ar arbitrary
Dimension meaning that you can have one
state that has unidimensional set of
children where you know like the
children lie in a line or maybe a b
dimensional set of set of children where
uh the children lie in a square or or a
disc or something like
that uh and the second thing that we
would like is the ability to mix between
both continuous and discrete
components uh because there is no reason
to restrict ourselves in the to The
Continuous set
only and one example or corollary of of
this thing that we want is
the yeah so we want the child set of a
state s it can be the union for example
of a continuous subset of the state
space uh and the exit State and this
exit states that we denote SF sometimes
uh basically if we are able to describe
a child set that is this Union of
continuous under this singon called SF
this literally means that we can
terminate trajectories early so we
cannot we do not require the
trajectories to have the same length
and uh just because we want trajectory
to not have the same length we need to
be able to describe child sets that
include this Singleton SF that uh will
refer to Formula One to by the exit or
the terminate
State and I'll just show you few
sketches of examples of environments
that satisfy this this
desiderat here in the bottom left corner
we consider an environment uh which is a
square so our points lie within this
field Square it can be anything within
the square and we can consider uh the
the starting point to be the bottom left
corner and then we can move anywhere
within this quarter dis that is shaded
here in Gray so by quarter dis it means
that the set of children of s0 the start
state is a continuous component of the
state space and it is B dimensional
because again we can move anywhere in
the dis and not just the circle but
after this first step we can constrain
the following steps to be within a
quarter Circle and I believe that you
see it a little bit uh here like we have
for example if you are in this point
here then the next state can lie within
this quarter Circle here that is
centered around the the current state
and of course it has to lie within
within the
square and uh so so this sketch here
shows two trajectories of different
lengths for example here after three
steps uh it was decided to the policy
decided to terminate so it went to the
exit State whereas here it required a
few more
steps uh another example that we would
like to be able to solve with with our
theory is the one where the number of
steps is fixed we start from an abstract
State S zero that does not represent any
physical property whatsoever but then we
will make for example 100 steps and at
each steps at each step we will sample
from a fixed distribution I mean not
fixed distribution of course like we
need to learn the parameters of the
distribution but like from a
distribution of a fixed family for
example we can set the family to be to
be gions and if our space is uh R2 like
the the ukan space we can just have for
example gions with fixed mean and
learned variance or gions with learned
mean and fixed variance or things like
that and after each step we will sample
from
ation until we reach the 100 step then
we have a state at which we are obliged
to
terminate and as a last example before
deling a little bit into the theory
which I promise won't be very
mathematical is the the image generation
problem uh where we start from an empty
canvas that's s0o then we have to choose
which
positions pixels to fill in and which
color to use for those pixels for
example here the set of uh of children
of s0 is a
Continuum
because sure there is a finite number of
positions just nine but there is an
infinite number or like a a
Continuum of values that each pixel can
take and
interestingly uh some states can have
multiple parents for example the state
here that has red and blue in this
positions have two parents here because
here the the forward policy has both a
continuous and discrete part this the
discrete part is the choice of the
location the pixel and the continuous
part is the choice of the color but the
backward policy only has a discrete
component uh here like if you want to to
choose what parent S2 has we just need
to remove one pixel so and the number of
pixels is
finite so this is a one typical
application of continuous
Chets so I mentioned before that we need
a mathematical tool that allows us
to describe a continue of children of
arbitrary dimensions and that allows us
to mix between both continuous some
discrete part and the appropriate M
mathematical tool we came up with is
transition kernels and very broadly
transition kernels can be seen as a
generalization of the concept of
measures I won't go much into the
details and I invite you to read the
paper if you want like the M
mathematical details but these
transistor kernels are basically
functions that take as input a state s
and a set a subset of the space and this
subset of the space we call it b b
belonging to this set Sigma here and
basically it tells you whether the set B
is accessible from s that's what you
need to remember from this so if Capa SB
is positive it just means that part of
the set B is accessible from us it means
it contains some of the children of s if
it is zero it means that b is not
accessible from s and of course there
are a few
Kats with open closed sets but again I
won't spend much time on it and going
back to the previous
examples uh where we had the quarter
disc and the quarter Circle we
can uh consider these two points here
for s0 for example Kappa s0b is zero if
if B is outside this quarter dis and uh
so that means that the support of Capa
s0 is the quarter disk and if you are
not at s0 if you are at another Point uh
then the support of Capa s is the
quarter dis for example if you are at
this point the support is the
corresponding quart sorry quarter Circle
not quarter
dis of course we have to add uh to to to
add the Singleton uh
SF to mention that we can exit at any
point for the other example where we
start from an abstract State S zero and
take a fixed number of steps our state
space uh is this abstract s0o Union uh
so we have to add a time stamp to our to
our states which are just normal vectors
so the support of Capa s0 is basically
the UK space but we need the time stamp
to be one so we need states of the form
S1 and if you are at a state St then the
the support is the states of the form s
t+1 uh so with this in mind like with
this transition kernel as the basis of
uh of our Theory uh the generalization
of the dag that we came up with we
called it uh we called it measurable
pointed graph
I promise I will not read this slide but
this is just for reference and maybe
like if you want to ask questions later
but you know it requires the
specification of the state space and
these Kels that tell us uh what are the
children and what are the parents of
every state uh I will however mention
these two last points here which are two
important points uh that you need to be
warry off if you want to train a
continuous giet the first one is you
need to make sure that your trajectory l
are bounded meaning that you do not want
some of your trajectories to
have know an infinite number of of steps
so that's something that you need to
enforce in in the design in the design
of the environment and of course there
is a mathematical formula for that and
you also need to ensure that all states
can be reached from s0o meaning that
there is no part of the the state space
that is
unreachable again of course there is a
mathematical formula for that uh I will
summarize now the key differences and
similarities between discrete and
continuous jonet uh so in the discrete
we talk about the children and parents
estate s whereas in the generalized
gence we need to talk about supports of
measures Kaa and Capa B uh we don't need
to spend a lot of time on measures it's
just like the mathematical tool that
that is required for the for the theory
but uh I just want to highlight that
there is an equivalence for the notion
of children and parents and instead of
the state flow function we need to talk
about a flow measure now and this
measure can have a density
VI uh instead of the forward policy we
we need to talk about a Ford kernel that
has of course a density that we call
that we write by small PF instead of the
backward policy we have a backward
kernel that again has a
density and instead of the reward
function we have a reward measure that
has a
density uh again these are just uh
mathematical details but at the end of
the day we have losses that look exactly
like I mean at least for re reward much
in detailed balance and balance these
losses look exactly like the their
discrete counterparts and let's just
focus focus for a second on the detailed
balance one uh where you know instead of
the the state flow function f we have
the state flow density U so that's u s
so Theta is just the set of parameters
and instead of the probability Mass
function PF we have the probability
density function small PF and same thing
here in the in the denominator and of
course you have pretty much the same
thing for the trajectory balance loss
that is applied to trajectories of
length
n and we don't need to spend time on
flow machine but there is
uh some small differences with the
discrete flow machine and that's because
of the choice that we made in the design
of uh of the structured space uh but all
in
all the training strategy is exactly the
same as the one with the that you have
learned for the discrete gonets you
sample your trajectories either
according to the current forward policy
or kernel
or you can add some noise to it if you
want to go off policy if you want to
explore the the state space more
efficiently and once you have that
trajectory uh you either decompose it
into transitions if you want to use the
detailed balance or consider the
trajectory as a whole if you want to use
trajectory balance you need to evaluate
these terms that are inside the loss and
in order to do that you you just need to
make a few forward passes in your neural
networks because basically this uh this
density U flow density U or the forward
kernel density PF for backward density
PB they're all parameterized by neural
networks that take as input a certain
State and once you do this
these forward passes you get what's
inside the square here and you know you
can just evaluate the loss gradient step
uh update the parameters repeat until
you're satisfied with the results
so that's about it for the theory and
I'll spend the next five to eight
minutes talking about a few experimental
results we have and then we'll have some
time for
questions uh so as a validation of this
Theory so this is not like a a really
interesting use case of gonets but more
should be seen as a validation of the
theory we consider a continuous version
of the hyper hypergrid toy task so this
hyper grid toy task has been used in
many gflo papers including like the
original one by Manuel uh so the state
space is this Square 01 squared and the
reward function is sparse that has four
modes and the modes are represented by
these four small squares by in
yellow and the transitions are follow
the the the example that I showed a few
slides ago that actually I will show
again uh they follow this rule here we
start from a zero we need to move within
the quarter circle of a given radius
that we call row uh for the first step
and after the first step we can either
terminate or move within the quarter
Circle again of the fixed radius or now
I'll go back to the other slide uh but
basically once we have this uh this
strategy that describes our measurable
point of the graph basically it tells us
what are the children what are the
parents of every
state uh we so this design basically it
makes the environment satisfy the
constraints that we had before so all
the the equations especially the last
two ones that I said that trajectory L
needs to be bounded and all states
reachable by by S zero so this is
satisfied and you can convince yourself
uh with it I suppose pretty easily uh so
in the second image so this one here we
see samples from a G Net Trend with
trajectory balance um actually it's not
really sample so we TR FL it we get
samples from that and then we fit a
kernel density estimator and we get this
nice uh control plot uh and the choice
of the policy we we we made is
uh that's why we have circles or discs
instead of squares it was like hard to I
mean it's you can probably prove that
it's impossible to reach Square uh
densities like this like with step
function uh with the choice of densi as
we
made
U so there is an important caveat of
continuous gonets that I would like to
highlight here
so in discrete gfets and this is
actually for the next three figures that
I would explain so for the discrete
gonets the policies whether it's forward
or backward they're parameterized with
Logics so the neural networks that take
as input EST State s they output Logics
that represent the a categorical
distribution because we have a finite
set of children and we just need loges
for
that but with continuous gfets we we
have
an extra degree of freedom because we
need to choose uh the family of
distributions we want for example we can
choose our policy to be Goan and for
that we need our neural network to
Output the mean and the variances or
maybe just the mean uh as a function of
the current
state
uh here for this example we we chose a
mixture of beta
distributions and why it's beta
distributions so beta distributions are
continuous distributions
over compact domains so it's
bounded as opposed to gions which are
unbounded so that's why we chose betas
and we chose it to be like mixture of
betas in order to to describe a richer
family of distributions so if you use
this mixture of beta distributions we
need to Output the mixture parameters
that you know parameters that tell you
uh I guess you know what mixture of
distribution is I don't need to explain
that and we need to Output the
concentration parameters of the
betas so this poses some something to be
you know it leads something to be extra
careful about uh basically we need to
make sure that the family of
distributions we are dealing with can
satisfy the detailed balance or the
trajectory balance conditions because if
we choose like a poor family uh maybe we
can never reach a zero loss because as
in like the detailed balance or tral
balance can never be
satisfied so this is what the next three
figures show so the first one so this
one here what does it show uh we
consider a uniform backward policy so uh
by by that I mean that every state has a
Continuum of parents that belong to a
quarter Circle that is in the bottom
left of that state of course the radius
r so we start with this uh backward
policy and we start with samples from
the reward distribution like we we
directly sample from the true reward
like because it's a toy task we have
access to the true reward and we with
these samples we take backward steps
using the backward policy until we reach
S1 S1 meaning the state that comes right
after s0 so that's why we get a
landscape or a support that is within
this quarter dis so this is row that is
the the radius and basically we bring
back the samples to S1 and we we fit a
kernal density estimator and we get dist
distribution here so this is the
distribution uh that this is what the
forward policy at s0o should lead to and
you know like there is a huge mass here
on the left Edge on the bottom Edge
there is some Mass here in the middle
and and it's pretty hard to match that
uh on one step using a mixture of
petas whereas if we consider a learned
backward
policy then uh the the if we do the same
process of starting with sample Su the
reward and bringing them back to S1 uh
then we get this nice plot here where
the mass is more regular and it is
easier to match that with a forward
policy that is a mixture of betas and
this is represented by the fifth figure
here and what this
means basically is
that whether it's detailed balance or
trajectory balance these conditions are
satisfied better if the backward policy
is learned mean by satisfied better it
means that the loss reaches something
that is closer to zero and this is again
shown by the Learning curves here in the
bottom uh maybe you can just focus on
trajectory balance the in blue for
radius equals to
025 where we see that if we fix PB to be
uniform then we Plateau to something
that's around three to three times 10^
Theus 3 whereas if we learn PB as well
then we are allowing PF to
match this learn PB more easily so the
the the detailed balance or director
balance condition is satisfied more
easily and we are able to uh to reach a
lower value for the
loss and of course this is also apparent
in detailed balance and also apparent if
we change the the
radies uh I'll stop talking about this
example now I I guess I spent more time
than expect expected but I'd be happy to
ask questions to answer questions about
it later on and I'll quickly talk about
this uh task of learning molecular
conformations for so we are given a
certain molecule where the atoms are
fixed but we have two degrees of freedom
which are these two angles p p and f or
and basically these two angles they
influence the energy of the molecule so
the molecule is more stable given some
configuration of these two
angles so one particularity of this St
and of this task and this is why I'm I'm
talking about it is that the state space
has an interesting topology uh because
these angles basically let's call they
live within zero to Pi and you know 2 pi
is the same thing as zero in if we talk
about angles uh so if we talk about just
one angle we are talking about a circle
because 2 pi is the same thing as zero
and if you talk about uh two angles we
talk about a circle that is horizontal
and the circle that is vertical to that
and we are given a Taurus and Taurus you
know something that looks like a donut
so our state space is aorus it's not the
normal ukian space and you can think of
it this way basically this space that is
represented by a square you can you
should wrap it wrap like w r a in your
head uh where the right Edge is the same
thing as the left Edge and the top Edge
is the same thing as the bottom
Edge so this is a projection of aurus in
in the Square so this left figure here
we have the energy landscape from which
the reward density is
derived of this is the true energy
landscape that tells you for
given value of c and V what is the
corresponding energy and here in the
right figure this is the energy
landscape that is obtained by fitting
kernel density
estimator on samples from a train gonet
and we can see that we can match the the
true energy landscape PR accurately uh
but again like the point of this slide
is just to mention that we are able to
to solve tasks that have an interesting
topology that is not just
ukan and uh finally as a last experiment
I'd like to mention uh this uh this one
about posteriors of graphs and
parameters so it's byan structure with
parameters that I mentioned in in the
first slide I'll show it again actually
before going to the details it's the the
task here where the goal is to start
from an empty Gra gra that represents
the nodes and then the goal is to add
the edges sequentially and once we are
satisfied with the the the structure
then we have to learn the parameters
that are associated to each one of those
edges and uh long story short is that we
we compare GF flet
[Music]
to before
comparing what this task is is you are
given a data set of let's say three
variables uh so it's just a set of
points in three dimensions and the goal
is to construct the graph between three
variables that tell you uh yeah which
are the parents which are the basically
the graph that generated this data and
we did this with three four or five
variables and uh back then and I guess
till now uh yeah sorry back then just
state-of-the-art algorithms were BCD
Nets and dips that they took this data
set and they output a posterior over
graphs and the numbers that you see here
are basically the Jensen shining
Divergence between the Learned posterior
and the true posterior
and long story short like the lower it
is the better and what we found is that
with the GF flet uh we we get
significant improvements so we
can
like surely say that g are B are
currently stateof theart algorithms I
don't know if something has come since
then this is like February
2023 uh
but either stateof theart or almost
stateof the art
today so this concludes my talk I just
want to shamelessly advertise this torch
gfn library that now supports continuous
environments and uh Joseph will probably
talk talk a little bit about that in the
next
presentation uh these are the ref
references that I used either the papers
or the figures that that I copied and
thank you for your attention and I'd be
happy to hear your questions
now anyone with questions is welcome to
come up to the
microphones yeah uh thank you for a nice
talk now I have a question about like
which policy we should use in practice
so in my understanding like in diffusion
models like people for example for
images people use gum policies and for
molecular confirmation I think people
use graph neural networks or something
but I'm curious like in G case like
let's say I want to sample from just exp
the world function like which policy we
should use in practice depending on
domains so sorry you said exp sample
from exp I'm not sure part of the
question if the goal is just to uh
sample from exponential like reward
function like let's say the goal is like
standard goal in
G and the domain is continuous like
image or like molecular
conation which policies like uh do you
recommend to use in
practice I don't think there is like a
generic answer to that it really depends
on the task at hand but if uh your
domain is unbounded then I would say
that the natural choice is to use a gion
for which you need to learn the mean and
or and variance uh but if your domain is
bounded then you need to consider other
distributions such as the one I
mentioned before like beta or mixture of
betas
uh by suppose that you know like I don't
have an example on the top of my head
right now but there might be many other
settings where uh the distribution you
are you should consider is more tailored
to the task at hand and one last point
is uh I'll go back to this slide here
where I mentioned that the choice of the
family of distributions is really
important because if you make the wrong
choice then maybe your detailed balance
oror balance conditions can never be
satisfied uh so yeah you need to be
careful about the choice of
of
distributions uh thank you uh for the
molecular confirmation which policies
did you
use uh so this one uh it followed the
the let me go back to this
slide it followed this example here
where there was a fixed number of steps
so it's it's called like stochastic
control with jlet where we start with
this absar States and then we do 100
steps and uh actually actually I
forgot which distribution we used maybe
like call I remember I think it's a gan
if I'm not mistaken because it's a
distribution for each Dimension you have
distribution over the circle I think
what was used is a mixture on of Fus
distributions or maybe circular gausin
Alex actually maybe can answer this
better yeah I remember yeah it's it was
10 steps in the paper and a mixture
of uh five components five for M
distributions yeah the details are in
the thank you very
much thank you for your
question there any other
questions no okay uh thank you very much
salm we'll resume
in